ok allez on marche et on accélère un
petit peu le pas quand vous êtes trop
près de quelqu'un quelque chose mais
pour juste dès qu'un espace de lille
vous y allez des exercices de théâtre
pour faire connaissance c'est la
première fois que les membres du nouveau
groupe plateaux du centre yvelines se
rend compte 22 groupes existent déjà
dans le département la particularité de
celui ci il est composé exclusivement de
commerçants
jusqu'à présent nous accompagnons
uniquement des industriels industrie
services à l'industrie
et aujourd'hui nous proposons
d'accompagner les commerçants commerces
de proximité et et services à la
personne par don via la méthodologie
plateau le commerce de proximité ne
bénéficient pas accompagnement de ce
soft de ce genre c'est un peu nouveau
les réseaux d'entreprise pour les
commerçants il nous semblait important
que le haut 6 et 7 me type pouvoir
apprendre à travailler ensemble
une méthode basée sur l'accompagnement
de dirigeants d'entreprises par des
cadres de grandes entreprises créées une
dizaine d'années à l'initiative de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles
le réseau plato permet un échange
d'outils d'expérience et surtout de
contacter les groupes sont suivis par un
cadre pendant deux ans éviter la
solitude être dans les changes parce que
vous en attendez est ce qui
économiquement ça peut vous aider
je ne sais pas encore économiquement
mais là ça a l'air d'être bien partie au
moins de 2 je pense que c'est plus
j'attends plus des des informations
il ya des personnes qui sont installés
depuis bien plus longtemps que moi qui
ont un un recul plus important pour
faire partie d'un groupe il faut se
rapprocher de la chambre de commerce
ici les commerçants se sont acquitté
d'un droit d'entrée de 2000 euros pour
les deux années de suivi du groupe avec
en moyenne un rendez vous par mois alors